turning to the war in Ukraine now
officials in the country's government
predict that Russia could launch a major
new offensive as soon as next week that
follows months of fighting in eastern
Ukraine involving a Russian paramilitary
group known as Wagner our Deborah patta
spoke with two of Wagner's members who
say they only went to Ukraine to avoid a
prison sentence
has been one of the most dangerous front
lines of this wall at the Vanguard the
kremlin-backed paramilitary Wagner Group
bolstered by recruits from Russian penal
colonies
we met two of these guns for hire seized
in the East now held by Ukrainian
Military Intelligence Sergey says he was
almost halfway into a 19-year sentence
for murder when Wagner Basi Afghani
pregosian made his prison pitch last
year
I needed to leave the prison one way or
another 10 years is a long time
so he made a deal with the devil
Frontline fighting in exchange for
freedom and cash he was told he'd be
fighting foreigners there
American mercenaries polish mercenaries
French we were told they were Nazis
Vlad said he'd already served two of his
three years for assault but the promise
of early release a white record and a
salary of three thousand five hundred
dollars proved too tempting
after just two weeks of training he says
he was sent against Ukrainian tanks with
nothing more than a machine gun
our brothers were getting killed in huge
numbers there were mountains of bodies
pregosian was recently filmed surveying
some of those bodies piled high in a
makeshift morgue near the front lines
the fighters Final Destination a special
vodna Cemetery in Russia filled with
freshly dug Graves and if his new
recruits refused to fight
you're just killed that's it you don't
agree with an order You're simply killed
and did you see this happen
yes one of the fighters was too scared
to fight they made him dig his own grave
and shot him he claims he saw three
comrades executed with a bullet to the
head but says he had no part in it there
are specially trained people to do that
a security group that can do anything to
you both men now believe they were
conned into going to the front line
everything we were told was utter lies
it was not ukrainians who wanted to kill
us we came to Ukraine to kill them they
insist they didn't commit any war crimes
and both say if they could turn back
time they'd choose the brutality of a
Russian prison cell over the Carnage of
a Ukrainian Battlefield
wow eye-opening reporting from Deborah
patta in UK